we've had an incredible 24 hours in the
United States I want to start today with
huge news out of Minneapolis where the
other three officers as they are known
involved in the death of George Floyd
have now been charged and the charges
against Derek shavon have been upgraded
from third-degree murder to
second-degree murder a lot to discuss so
starting off with reminder Derek shavon
is the officer in the viral video that
spurred the national and even global
protests the officer putting his knee to
George Floyd's neck for many minutes
before George Florida ultimately died
the three officers visible in the video
sort of standing around as this happens
have now been charged with aiding and
abetting second-degree murder and aiding
and abetting second-degree manslaughter
second-degree murder and aiding and
abetting second-degree murder punishable
by up to 40 years in prison
manslaughter aiding and abetting
manslaughter punishable by up to 10
years in prison now let's talk about the
Derek shovin charges and this is there's
a lot of detail here that's important
the original charges against Derek
shavon were third degree murder and
second degree manslaughter the murder
charge has now been upgraded to
second-degree murder this is very
important because second-degree murder
carries with it number one a much more
serious potential sentence but also
number two potentially a more difficult
to prove case for the prosecution in a
sense sort of maybe except that the
third degree murder charges when you
look at the statute also may not have
been the right ones for the situation so
but again we've got to look at what the
statutes say in Minnesota a third degree
murder charge is defined as quote
whoever without intent to effect the
death of any person meaning without
deliberately trying to kill someone
causes the death of another by
perpetrating and act eminently dangerous
to others and evincing a depraved mind
not
or evincing a depraved mind and evincing
a depraved mind without regard for human
life is guilty of murder in the third
degree so this is from the 2019
Minnesota Statutes and what shavon did
would be very tough to prove in a court
of law
as what's called a depraved mind murder
so you can make the case not that the
charge should be second degree versus
third degree based on the severity so to
speak of what Derek shavon is accused of
doing
but because the third degree murder
statute includes this depraved mind
component so instead we have second
degree murder here there are two types
of second-degree murder in Minnesota
Statutes intentional and unintentional
if shawhans restraint of George Floyd
caused Floyd's death he could be guilty
of unintentional second-degree murder
even if he was not trying to kill George
Floyd it would be very difficult to
prove in a court of law based on what
we've seen that shavon was trying to
kill George Floyd it seems as though
unintentional second-degree murder is
the statute under which George Floyd's
death would fall from the perspective of
Derek shawhans actions now there's one
more analysis here about this that's
less about what you can prove but more
about what shavon is likely to plead
down to so let me kind of frame this up
for you in a different way if this goes
to trial I think it's going to be tough
but not impossible to get a guilty
verdict against Derek shavon that has
nothing to do with my opinion about what
went down it is merely my understanding
of how these trials often work and what
the law is so bear with me here we have
two autopsies that were done of George
Floyd so far that I've read in one of
those autopsies the cause of death is
not alone the actions of Derek shavon
the cause of death says it was not
asphyxiation by Derek shavon and it was
at the wrists
rent used by Derrick shavon combined
with pre-existing medical conditions and
possible intoxication now you and I may
think that that's BS and indeed there's
a second autopsy which says something
very different which says that the death
was indeed caused by asphyxiation as a
result of Derrick shawhans actions but
my point is if this goes to trial a good
defense attorney which Derrick shavon
will certainly have is very much able to
introduce reasonable doubt about whether
shawhans actions definitely are the
cause of George Floyd's death by
focusing on the one autopsy that says
you know there were pre-existing medical
conditions that were a factor possible
intoxication and restraint you bring in
some medical examiner that they'll find
and say doctor whoever given this
autopsy is it possible that absent
George Floyd's medical conditions and
possible intoxication that he could have
survived the way that he was restrained
by Derrick shavon
yes counsel that's possible so you and I
both understand that this is apparently
BS but you would then have a fight a
legal fight where the defense is
introducing doubt and the prosecution is
saying well we have a different autopsy
this OP topsy does say that George Floyd
was asphyxiated by Derrick shavon but it
becomes a fight and remember you only
need reasonable doubt to acquit the
standard of evidence in a civil trial
may well be a preponderance of evidence
does it seem like 51% of the evidence
points to Derrick shawhans
responsibility in a criminal trial you
need only introduce reasonable doubt so
this gets me back to the reason for
moving from third degree murder to
second degree murder
is the idea that you go to a
second-degree murder charge because it
carries a higher penalty so that you
increase the desire from Derrick shavon
to plead to something smaller to avoid a
trial altogether which may or may not go
well for the prosecution that's another
possibility as to why you would have
seen an elevated charge from third
degree murder to second degree murder
needless to say it is correct
to elevate the charge the second-degree
murder based on our reading of the
Minnesota statutes and it is a good
thing that the other officers have been
charged and all were brought in
yesterday this is going to be this is
going to be a very long thing it in by
every indication this will not be
resolved for far longer than the current
protests are likely to go so we've got
to really buckle in and realize that
this is going to be a long process
speedy trial okay it is still going to
be a long and protracted process